les lumières de la révélation masculine
est attribué à félix léfèvre et benjamin
voisins là étaient 85 prédit que ce fait
21 ans et benjamin voisin 24 ans pour
tous deux étaient 85 de françois ozon et
et leur sixième film déjà mais le
premier film ensemble
il semble difficile de dissocier leur
prestation dans cette histoire d'amour
universel adapté d'un roman anglais sur
deux adolescents un été et rend verne
est renforcée par l'incroyable alchimie
entre nos deux lauréats
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir à tous les
deux bravo c'est vrai comme comme le
disait laurent c'est difficile de vous
dissocier tous les deux tellement vous
êtes en fusion dans ce film je suppose
que vous étiez très heureux d'être
nommés ensemble dans cette catégorie est
maintenant de recevoir le prix tous les
deux ensemble ouais merci je pense que
c'est des rôles qu'on a travaillé
vraiment en collaboration dans une
collaboration affective aussi autant que
professionnel et c'est vrai que je pense
que chacun des deux rôles n'existerait
pas sans l'autre
du coup on est très heureux de mettre en
compétition et d'être ensemble
qu'est-ce que vous avez une question oui
tout à fait je trouve que votre dieu
fonctionne merveilleusement bien bravo
les garçons alors est ce que vous savez
qui françois ozon a choisi un prisonnier
moi je sais qu'ils préfèrent c'est félix
le rôle principal qui a été choisi et
sert au miam
j'ai été auditionnée vous pour voir si
la miss marché entre félix et moi mais
c'est félix qualité ça marche très bien
bravo le plaisir merci et félix vous
avez dû vous avez votre
a comme on pourra le choix alors ouvrir
les dossiers françois il m'a appelé le
soir juste avant quitte à peine il m'a
appelé et m'a dit bon qu'est ce que tu
en penses pas à main il va ou pas et moi
je lui dis tu te pose encore la question
est là et a appelé et c'était bon et
c'était parti alors rester à côté de
nous le le film raconte une rencontre un
premier amour estivale moi je vous
propose de regarder un extrait du film
où on voit à quel point l'alchimie a
opéré entre vous deux c'est juste
magnifique
tu t'es pas vu tu lisais la cour sur ton
rafiou comme si j'étais pas là tu m'as
laissé tout ranger et pendant que moi je
me tapais tous que j'aimerais le bateau
a disparu avec ton nouveau joujou tu me
larguer tu te ramène comme une fleur à
11 heures du mat en pensant que tout va
être comme d'hab
non moi je suis pas ta boniche je suis
pas ta disposition ok mon pote c'est bon
t'as fini
non je veux savoir pourquoi t'as fait ça
moi je veux tu veux pas le savoir moi je
crois que tu es juste jaloux mais t'en
fais pas ça te passera par est avec ce
ton sur train d'expliquer la alex
à ce que tu appelles ça une explication
tu m'expliques koala ok tu sais quoi
calmons nous faisons la paix je me suis
mal conduit alors maintenant on revient
comme avant on laisse tomber et on est
en retard est à cette fois à l'instant
laurie parler d'alchimie entre vous deux
elle a vraiment raison parce que c'est
incroyable donc vous former à l'écran on
travaille bien sûr mais on essaie de
laisser aussi un peu voire beaucoup de
spontanéité parce que quand on vous
connaît un petit peu vous êtes vraiment
malheur de deux caractères totalement
différent on s'appuie là-dessus on
s'appuie là-dessus et je crois que c'est
pour ça que françois nous à conjuguer
ensemble et c'est ce qui fait plaisir
felix avait une intériorité et moins une
extériorité et la conjugaison des deux
amène le film est
et c'était un plaisir de faire de faire
ça et françois-xavier dernière option
oui alors la presse internationale adore
les films
est-ce que vous avez une appréhension
particulière comment vous sentez par
rapport à cet aperçu de là on sort de
deux promotions on a parlé en anglais
français ou en anglais français avec la
presse si on avait tellement
nationalités différentes c'est à dire
c'est un plaisir une chance d'avoir le
monde qu'ils y qui regardent le film ça
fait plaisir
ben moi l'idée de d'avoir ce film qui
parcourt un petit peu les pays surtout
en ce moment où on peut pas voyager
c'est quelque chose qui nous fait du
bien et puis on espère que ça va plaire
un petit peu partout et puis c'est une
histoire universelle disponibles quelle
est la clé la question qui revient le
plus par la presse internationale
etes-vous amis ou amoureux
elle est alors pendant les trois heures
j'ai pas répondu à la question
elle exhale faire bon on est on est on
est amis est ce que tu crois que non on
est on est amis évidemment après on a on
a travaillé cet amour pour le film qui
s'est développée après un vraie relation
amoureuse plus tard mais vraiment dans
les personnages on va vous laisser
tranquille la lumière de la révélation
masculine ce soir je vous remercie merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup de spontanéité
et pourrait pour ses filles merci à vous